Time magazine's
person of the year
is our president-elect
and person who definitely
at some point in his life
has yelled, "Seize him!"
-Donald Trump.
-(laughter)
Now, he's an '80s movie villain,
you guys.
He's an '80s movie villain.
He's the one, who whatever that
story is, he keeps the nerds
from accomplishing
whatever thing it is, and then,
they got to, in the end, like,
teach him a lesson.
He's like, "Nerds!"
Like, that's him.
Now, if you're not a Trump fan,
I would like to remind you
the title goes to someone
who is influential,
not someone who is necessarily,
like, the greatest person ever.
If that was the case,
every year,
it would just go to The Rock.
I mean,
he's the greatest person ever.
-I mean, every...
-(applause and cheering)
Why don't they just... do that?
To help.... to help keep things
in perspective,
here's what a wise man
once said on Twitter.
Quote, "The Time magazine list
"of the 100 most influential
people is a joke
"and a stunt of a magazine
that will,
like Newsweek, soon be dead.
Bad list!"
Who said that again? Oh, right.
Time magazine's 2016
man of the year,
-Donald Trump. -Oh!
-(people groaning)
Uh, so, comedians,
what other list
does Donald Trump
consider to be bad?
Joe Randazzo.
Uh, list of the 2.8 million
more people who actually voted
for Hillary Clinton
in the election than him.
All right, I will give you
points for that.
(applause and cheering)
Mamrie Hart.
The waiting list
for a new Slovenian wife.
-HARDWICK: Points.
-(laughter)
-Points.
-(applause)
Who wants
to be the second First Lady?
HART (laughing):
Yeah.
-Jon Gabrus.
-Schindler's list.
Not the movie,
but the actual list.
-Okay, all right, points.
-(laughter, groaning, applause)
I'll give you points for that.